je pense qu'une activité sportive est
importante au delà du fait que ce soit
pour le corps aussi pour l'esprit jeu se
défouler de passer ça permet de ne pas
s'énerver pour rien je peins
personnellement moi ça m comme ça tu
fais quoi comme sport du fitness mais
j'essaye plein de choses tennis yoga
pilates
jacques rogge à vous je fais du yoga non
mais c'est quoi votre position préférée
au yoga
c'est là
le le lotus et lotus mais le papier
toilette
c'est mme combes déroule
non mais non dans le pilat le pirate ou
6 mai jadot réponse
sans lendemain meilleur et j'adore
également j'adore le film le pilates des
caraïbes
sophie adore alors johnny depp et tous
adorent non mais est donc ouais donc une
activité ou une activité sportive pour
le corps mais aussi l'esprit très
important seul donc je pense qu'il faut
faire attention à sa nutrition parce
qu'on est ce qu'on mange ce qu'on mange
ouais
carrément on n'est pas bien
on est ce qu'on range à tony key siens
c'est tony sans beaucoup de chemin
be well en espagnol tu peux dire un
petit mot d'espionnage voilà
[Applaudissements]
mais sa quête je finis les deux conseils
j'y vais on a deux matches importants du
match un important était la voiture tu
veux
on te lâche pas mais heureusement tu me
lâches pas inquiète pas elle rigole pas
par contre les affaires sont prêtes tout
est prêt et on va gagner les deux
matches il a joué dans l'équipe
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
deuxième conseil donc le deuxième
c'était la nutrition bien manger alors
c'est bien manger quoi faire manger
alors c'est pour ça que d'en produire
des clips un peu marre et c'est pour ça
que vous savez vous pouvez retrouver des
conseils soient faites par une
nutritionniste professionnels qui vous
donne des conseils pour mieux manger
d'ailleurs on peut manger ce qu'on veut
mais d'une bonne façon c'est à dire
quand même si je mange in by prenez
plutôt une pizza fait pas maison plutôt
que fait votre propre pizza plutôt
qu'aller dans away donc je me demandais
barre de viol au cours
desquels john comme toujours tout
l'attirail pour faire une telle je pense
que ça peut être très simple de femmes
qui a soi même d'accord je vais voir ce
que je peux faire et troisième conseil
et le troisième c'est je dirais prendre
soin de soi c'est à dire prendre du
temps pour soi se l'imposé voilà c'est
ça je te jure que c'est vrai mais cela
change leur sang je te jure médecins qui
quittent tu trouves le plus épanoui dans
les chroniqueurs comme ça à vue d'oeil
tu penses à et le plus
zen je pense que valérie mais j'ai pas
la rencontrer dans les loges et je
trouve qu'elle a une sorte d d'aisance
et elle est ré sonne allait sous le
maillot naturellement donc je pense qu'à
se trouver à fait compris à ceux connais
pas quand tu prends autant de zahia rien
faire
mais c'est vrai
ah oui sinon qu'ils aient encore bas
j'ai pas eu le temps encore discuté avec
ton mais ils sont tous très souriant et
très chaleureux donc je pense qu'il sera
bel et bien en février et qui vit
pleinement je trouve alors ils vivent
sainement revoit castanet
voilà seulement au regard de staline ont
naturellement trois belles saisons qui
soit équilibrée quoi voilà c'est un
équilibre et huawei
garder l'équilibré je trouve que oui je
trouve que oui il a été très fermement
il était charmant donc je pense que si
l'équilibré juste qu'ils savaient pas
que tu étais pas célibataire
je connais il berden mais c'est non moi
quand je l'apprécié énormément
magnifique elle est magnifique et saint
livre est génial bah oui je lai la
complimenter sur son livre et sur elle
même j'ai toujours apprécié maciré
comptes a toujours appris la wii merci
beaucoup franchement j'adore je sais je
sais que tu as des liens très forts avec
mon mari je les adore je laime il est
voilà donc tu la touche pas cela
cet escarpin non mais je tenais dans mes
choix ici on festin qui ont échoué mais
transfère aux matons mari il va très
bien il vient d'être rappelle son mari
ses baquets
ils ont mis la photo elle a d'ailleurs
que le roi sport mon frérot d'ailleurs
que j'aime et embrasse aussi m'a demandé
de te faire passer j'oublie mon
portefeuille que j'ai voulu un jour à
mes way est pardon pardon vous laissez
vos portefeuilles chez eux ou bien mon
portefeuille chez toi un jour ah ouais
ouais ouais et le récupérer
[Applaudissements]
bah ouais je le trouvais vachement génie
ankama frérot tu peux me donner mon
portefeuille la veille c'est vrai et
dans ma voiture voilà exerçait dans ma
voiture s'ils oubliaient tombeur de lens
va essayer dans la voiture de raymond
j'en ai refaire un autre et
elle est allée en tout cas je te jure tu
es ex et une altération m6 ou pas pour
l'instant on a fait une petite pause
j'espère pouvoir reprendre donc nous non
ta d'oran à 6 6 dans le groupe canal+
toujours le pilote avait fait la même
proposition à nicolas waldorf alors
j'aime bien ben ouais mais je prends
toute l'équipe les deux et après on les
adore j'adore cette émission c'est moi
je kiffe c'est ma canne dans le mille
voilà ça voilà c'est mon kilt des
missions passées grâce à cette émission
que j'ai pu justement entreprendre de
faire ça c'est sain c'est quoi parce que
j'ai rencontré des centaines de
personnes qui savaient qu'il y avait un
peu lâché la rampe qui s'était abandonné
et moi j'ai fait ce livre pour moi à la
base parce que j'avais une petite
dépression et j'avais besoin de me
donner voilà des objectifs et je me suis
dit rencontrant tous ces genres je vais
le faire pour tout le monde là tu veux
là tu es au top tu vas beaucoup mieux tu
es au top oui oui j'ai suivi tous mes
conseils voilà je vous le dis les à
apprendre à s'aimer en 365 jours mer
tiens à dire que je suis pas légitime de
donner des conseils sur la nutrition sur
la coiffure etc parce que ce n'est pas
mon métier donc il ya plein de conseils
d'experts professionnels en plus qui
sont utiles sont venus m'aider et qui
ont fait de ce deux stages en bas de ce
livre quelque chose de global et de très
complet ben bravo en tout cas mais m
[Applaudissements]